hey guys I think I am a tasty and
BuzzFeed video producer and I love
cooking a lot I also love baking
especially sweet things and today I am
gonna try and make banana bread using
ten hacks that my friend Eddie found for
me off of the internet you guys might
have seen really this before she made
cake and cookies using a bunch of hacks
and they turned out pretty awesome I
love banana bread and I have a go-to
recipe that I've been doing since I was
in college it's super moist and it
always gives me that like beautiful
fluffy texture
I love making them in muffin pans
because they're perfect to share let's
get started I have my bananas with me
and my banana bread recipe usually asks
for three bananas but the first hack I
saw said that you should always add more
bananas than you need so I'm going to
add in another banana it's supposed to
give it like a bolder banana flavor
which sounds promising
but I just hope that it doesn't affect
the ratio of all the other ingredients
you guys might have noticed that my
bananas aren't exactly that ripe yet but
supposedly there's a way to instantly
ripen them by putting them in the oven
and baking them for 15 to 20 minutes
I've already lined my baking sheet with
foil and I'm just going to put my four
bananas on here and what I'm gonna do is
bake them in the oven at 300 degrees
Fahrenheit for 15 to 20 minutes I'm
really really curious to know how that's
gonna work out because it could be super
useful so let's check back in in 15 to
10 minutes okay guys it has been 20
minutes and this is what our bananas
look like right now they are a
completely different color so I flipped
them around around half way into like
cooking time this is what the hack said
that they would turn out to be but it's
still like so amazing seeing that
transition we are gonna peel it open now
and scrape off the insides I guess into
a bowl it deftly smells a little bit
interesting right now I have to admit
that it does not look the most appealing
right now but it is very very soft it's
very tender so I guess that's right so
now I'm just going to really quickly
peel the rest of my bananas it gets the
job done so I think it does work there's
definitely a lot of water don't you guys
in felt like all this liquid is in there
so I'm going to drain the liquid now I'm
just gonna mush it together and then add
the rest of our wet ingredients now that
we have the banana all mashed together
and I've also put some eggs in it we are
going to go into our brown sugar this is
what my brown sugar looks like right now
it is rock-hard so what I'm gonna do is
actually follow this hack that says to
microwave it to soften it and to do that
we are gonna grab some paper towels and
just wet them a little bit drape the wet
towel over the brown sugar I think we're
gonna microwave them for like 20 second
intervals and then you know kind of try
to break them apart every 20 seconds
until they're completely soft again so I
ended up microwaving this for 60 seconds
it actually worked obviously there's
still a little bit of lumps but they're
super easy to break apart now this is
around a cup of brown sugar so I'm just
gonna go ahead and add my brown sugar
into the banana puree that we have once
the brown sugar and banana is combined
we can now add in the buttermilk and
here's the thing if you don't have
buttermilk at home the hack is that you
can make your own buttermilk by
combining lemon juice with milk and
honestly this is already something that
I do a lot so I love this hack let it
sit for five to 10 minutes and we should
have buttermilk there's 1 cup of milk
here and 1 tablespoon of lemon juice and
we really only need a quarter cup of
buttermilk so I'm gonna add just a
little bit in here this is what our
banana bread make sure it looks like
right now looks like very thick apple
sauce I'm gonna add in my oil I like
using oil instead of butter for this
because I feel like the oil is actually
what makes the banana bread so fluffy
and like
keeps it so moist adding a splash of
vanilla as well supposedly adding this
adds like a subtle citrus flavor and
also makes it a little more moist so if
that's true
this would be really cool to see baking
powder and baking soda and so one of the
hacks actually says that there are ways
to test your baking powder and baking
soda to make sure that they're still
good to use which could be helpful
considering how these are some of the
things that sit around our pantry for
forever for baking soda what they said
is that you should get a bowl grab some
vinegar or lemon juice anything that's a
little bit acidic and then put some
baking soda in there if your baking soda
it's still good you should get some
bubbles my baking soda is good to go it
passed so I'm gonna stop it out now and
test out my baking powder with baking
powder you need to get some hot tap
water I'm going to add in our baking
powder and if all is good
I should also be getting some bubbles so
I think this is a pretty good test if
you just have these lying around in your
pantry and you're not sure if they're
still good to go now you know when to
put them on your grocery list I'm gonna
go ahead and add the baking soda and
baking powder to the flour so after
that's done I'm just adding in some salt
a little bit of cinnamon and also some
freshly grated nutmeg gonna give this a
quick toss all right so now that I have
my dry ingredients and my wet
ingredients I'm going to combine the two
slowly sift this in and make it into our
final banana bread mixture it is looking
pretty good you guys so far it's looking
pretty promising I'm glad we made it
this far Matt all our hacks the next
step really is to put it into muffin
tins
and you found this cool hack where you
can actually use parchment paper as
cupcake liners if you don't have you
know the normal cupcake holders what do
you want to do
in parchment paper and find a glass or a
cup that kind of fits into the muffin
pan what we're gonna do is essentially
put the parchment paper on top of the
pan and kind of just squish it down and
then what we're gonna do is essentially
just like fold it in so that it retains
its shape best as we can so then when I
remove it we get this shape that is not
quite like a cupcake liner but I guess
that it gets the job done and we're
gonna squish that in there I can see
where this is going and I feel like it
would be effective I just don't know if
it is worth the time and effort so I
think I'm just going to test maybe one
or two on the side the other thing that
I saw was that you could use an ice
cream scoop to scoop the batter out I
also only have a baby ice cream scoop so
I'm not sure how useful this is going to
be but we can give it a few tries you
can actually try to fill your muffin
cups a lot more than you usually do so I
feel like normally we say like you can
stop around 2/3 if you wanted to look
more like the muffins we see outside
they say the more batter the better I am
going to fill all of these up almost
like three quarters of the way full
maybe they'll give us that beautiful
size we want I have my muffin tin here I
filled everything up we are gonna pop
this in the oven and bake it for 20
minutes and we'll see how it compares to
the original ones
it smells amazing in here it just smells
like banana bread everywhere this is one
of the reasons why I love making it at
home i drizzled some icing on it it's a
lot bigger than what my normal size is
this is what mine usually turn out like
and this is what we have today texture
is what I am interested in and also
flavor so we're gonna give this a little
taste test
they're both really good they taste very
very similar I feel like there's an
extra sweetness in this one like a
different layer of sweetness in there so
I don't know if it's the orange and if
it is then I'm all for it this is
actually really good
like surprisingly really good
considering the amount of things we
threw in there in terms of banana taste
I really think like throwing your
bananas in the oven and letting it just
like write them real fast is a hack that
is totally usable you still get that
texture everything else is on point so
I'm really really pleasantly surprised
it just doesn't look that appealing in
the beginning remember the one with the
parchment paper this is what it looks
like now I kind of really like it I know
I said it was a little more
time-consuming
but if you don't have cupcake liners it
actually turns out to be pretty cool
before we go there is one last hack we
have to try which is to toast the banana
bread and add butter on it it's supposed
to make it even better I have some
toasted banana bread and put some butter
on it and just spread it around Wow I am
literally like drooling and my mouth oh
that looks so good
I mean it's butter and it's warm and
toasty this has to be good
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this might be one of my favorite
hack [ __ ] this is so good it's like that
perfect crunch on the outside and the
soft sweetness on the inside and it is
perfect this was super fun I'm so glad
that we got to test out all these hacks
today I hope you guys try out the ones
that worked and other than that I'll see
you guys next time
[Music]